they're actually terrific because it's a
venue where you get people who are many
of whom are quite influential in various
different spheres and the beauty of it
is that you get people from all walks
from politics from finance economy
medicine science the media all together
in a very relaxed atmosphere where it's
just the general feeling of everybody
interacting talking to each other taking
the time to have a conversation and then
you have these various seminars that are
set up to specifically address a
particular issue and it's very very
informative and energizing to hear the
experts in the field get a presentation
and then get questioned by the audience
as to why they are taking this
particular viewpoint so it's a very very
stimulating miliar to be in a venue it's
it's it's it's invaluable and also it's
invaluable to get to meet people that
you may be able to help and could help
you in your own endeavours